so what was the moment where you guys
each had your realization of I am in a
freaking Star Wars movie right now
coming on to sentencing Chewbacca was
what's that air that yeah yeah or just
seeing like the Falcon leg it was really
intense like I don't know that those
moments kind of never stopped for me no
they just kept coming like you know you
at the beginning of course you're like
oh I see this droid and I see this like
it's cool but then it's just it's just
one after another you're like in the
desert and there's a town and there's
like you know it just never stopped from
me but how do you stay in the character
when you're having these with this many
freaking moments like you're walking
into the cockpit of the Millennium
Falcon the kid in you has to be losing
his mind but you still have to be Lando
yeah we were given quite a lot of space
to lose our minds to me fast but yeah
actually like they took the lead I think
they made the decision to take us on
like a few days before and just like let
us be like yeah we're going to go and
because then I think everyone regrets
for a long time yeah and eventually we
can't pull ourselves together I don't
know how to describe it you guys the
have a sort of human droid relationship
like we have not seen in Star Wars
before is that fair I think that's fair
yeah they may have been going on they
just haven't been talking about the
droids and the people are doing it I
mean yes
the action figures isn't that water
right I mean like yes I'd be remiss if I
don't think like at least 15 percent of
people are like Alexis quite yeah did
you keep any capes oh I'm not allowed
although I mean like they did make me
they made me a pillow from one of the
capes like I had extra material so they
made a pillow and I still wear to the
cape my stuff and I took apart and
they're like please don't do that house
like you can't stop me this was a gift
thank you so much guys